I know it's important that these press
releases are done on top
very recent as a matter fact as I was
walking out the door we were getting a
little bit of an update so I just wanted
to let y'all know I appreciate y'all's
patience and waiting for this press
release the fire did intensify overnight
on Monday due to a temporary loss of
water pressure and water resources
between the hours of 4:00 and 10:00 p.m.
the loss of water pressure was due to
the malfunction of two fire boat pumps
that were providing water to the
firefighters operating on the scene
water pressure and water resources have
been restored and emergency responders
continue working on suppressing the fire
on tanks 80 - 280 - 380 - 580 - 680 -
880 - 11 tanks 80 - nine in 80 12 were
empty and have collapsed earlier this
morning
tanks 80 - 14 in 80 - 15 both containing
pyrolysis gasoline and we refer to that
as pie gas and I will refer to that
later as pie gas are confirmed to be on
fire emergency responders continue to
work with foam and water to control and
contain the fire additional resources
including a specialty third party
firefighting team and their equipment
have arrived on the scene regarding air
quality all detections recorded by CT eh
were below levels that would represent
health concerns individuals with health
concerns should contact health care
professional
we continue to take precautions to
further reduce the risk of explosion all
personnel are accounted for and there
have been no serious injuries reported
as a result of this incident from the
onset of this incident
ITC officials have worked closely with
first responders around the clock to
contain the fire and to inform the
community regarding this incident the
safety and well-being of the surrounding
communities our employees our first
responders and the environment continue
to be a top priority and we remain
committed to providing information to
you as it develops ITC is coordinating
its response with representatives of the
Texas Commission on Environmental
Quality the US Environmental Protection
Agency the US Coast Guard Harris County
and other federal state and local
agencies the most recent update that I
got as I was walking out the door from
icy has changed a little bit from the
press release that was scheduled so I
want to start with the tanks that are
currently right now on fire we have 80 -
380 - 580 - 680 - 8 and 80 - 15 are on
fire 80 - 9 and 80 - 12 were the two
tanks that we did not have any chemical
or product in it and they have collapsed
80 - 280 - 11 and 80 - 14 have burnt out
meaning that there is no more fuel in
those tanks so they are not on fire 80 -
280 - 11 and 80 - 1480 - 180 - 980 -
seven
80 - 10 in 80 - 13 have not caught on
fire fully and fire are 80 - 380 - 580 -
680 - 8 and 80 - 15 5 tanks are on fire
and I just received that from incident
command we'll start over here right
there
can you repeat the question David Waskom
the water that's going into the ship
channel is basically from the firefight
all the water going into this diked area
as well as foam we've got booms down
we've got a third party contractor
shrink cleaning it up at this time we
have not had any reports of foam or
Sheen going into the outfall which would
then go into the ship channel we're also
looking at sampling we've been sampling
around the clock every hour for pH Co D
and other things and we have TCEQ
working with us to help analyze those
samples neighbors are saying they're
fine foot on their car
we continue to monitor the air quality
to working with seat tech we're also
working with EPA that you actually flew
a plane through the plume the last
couple days there's still within safe
levels and we continue to monitor all
the chemicals that we have in our tank
form plus VOCs which is a volatile
organic compound as well as Co co2
oxygen so I'll talk on that for just a
moment because right now I'll be more
than glad to give you a summary on that
but right now we want to focus on the
incident we do have a history we've been
in this community for 40-plus years and
I'll be more than glad to give you any
information that you need but I'd really
like to focus on the incident right now
I can tell you that ITC is a safe
company I have worked here for over 20
years and I believe in it and I can
guarantee you that we would never do
anything that is wrong to hurt our
environment our environment is key to
our our children's future it's key to
everything that that we need as humans
and we are working our hardest to get
this current incident under control but
if you will leave your name and contact
information I will reach out to you
personally thank you so much
that's what we're monitoring we're also
monitoring for benzene as well high gas
is not benzene but there's benzene my
gosh
yes
updated with their all gasoline
components 80 - 3 is a gasoline blend
stock 80 - 5 is xylene which also goes
into making gasoline
you also have an 80 - 6 another gasoline
what we call blend stock which is a
gasoline for your cars
you also got naphtha which is a key
ingredient that's the first thing that
went into making gasoline and then you
have buy gas which is the same thing
these are all gasoline components so
we're analyzing all around the area plus
with the help of Houston Harris County
they have monitors in the area for
benzene as well so the Harris County
monitors they have for benzene and other
elements that's a public access record
out let me just talk about that for just
a moment we have on our website we have
established under news media you can go
there and we are going to put post the
immediate most recent results of all air
monitoring that we have we're going to
post it right there I would have it
takes a while to print all that out we
were getting current information and
things we're changing all morning long
so I we set this up and we will post it
as soon as we have it you can see the
last one that we gave you yesterday is
already posted on there and the media
releases are being posted on there so
please refer to that
so we have a lot of resources with it
right now I have the Harris Fire Chief I
don't know if you can make a comment
about the timing hi Laurie Christensen
Harris County Fire Marshal actually as
they stated we are in support in Harris
County is at level two readiness with
the Harris County Office of Emergency
Management what we would like to
encourage you I want to say this first
please ask not only yourselves who are
really good at it but the public please
follow ready Harris we're putting out
press releases social media and those
things so we are putting that
information out as soon as we can what I
will say is every available resource we
are ensuring from the Harris County
partnership that we are supplying those
we're working with industrial partners
our city partners our liaisons with in
other agencies even some of the
surrounding communities to ensure all
the resources that are available are
here you heard them mentioned earlier
they have actually called in additional
resources from out of state to assist
them as some of the things that they're
doing yes the fire continues to burn we
do have people in the incident command
center they're working diligently the
first responders that are on-site
obviously we are concerned about the to
the community safety we're also
concerned about their safety we're very
proud to say that at this time nobody's
been injured and the first responders
are doing a fantastic job I will also
say that the Harris County Office of
Emergency Management is going to
continue to put out as much information
as we can but we're going to rely on ITC
to put out information from their
company site so when you ask how many
and I know that was your direct question
how long will this last we talked about
that fuel has has burned off and we've
said from the beginning that may be what
has to happen but I can't tell you is
how long that will take
to burn off what I'll tell you is we're
doing everything we can to keep it
cooled keep from going on it bring in
those resources that are needed and it
may burn itself out so we don't know
what that timeline is we're relying on
experts that we have out in the field
especially personnel that have
specialties in this in this type of
event to ensure that we're doing
everything possible again I'm not going
to give you a timetable because as we
know overnight it has changed and we
know the weather I know that Jeff
Flender has been giving updates and so
Jeff has been giving that information
out to the weather it's artificial time
limits are foolish but if I could just
ask a question is it my turn or if you
go ahead over here hand up oh right
there I thought you have your hand up at
this point in time we don't anticipate
any explosions the news that I got as I
was walking out the door appears to be a
positive approach going forward and
we're hoping that the wind stays the way
it is and that things continue miss
Richardson yesterday afternoon you said
you were making headway you had progress
then overnight this expands to two more
tanks there are five that haven't caught
fire yet with what degree of certainty
can you say that those five will not
burn before this is over
I cannot say with a degree of certainty
I can say that the conditions that they
are applying to those tanks we are doing
everything humanly possible to protect
them and to protect all of our
communities and our people and I can
tell you that with 100% certainty but
tell me inside the incident command what
do they believe is going to happen to
those five times they do not believe
they are going to explode or catch on
fire at this point in time why are they
so certain about because they've worked
in this industry and worked with these
chemicals for a very long time and my
Icee is composed of many folks that have
worked and all the plants out
they're a great great group of people
our SEMA channel mutual aid group has
supported us in in a phenomenal way they
have given us many many resources and we
appreciate everything they have done I
believe the communities have also the
city of Deer Park the city of the port
and many other communities surrounding
us have provided as resources and we
appreciate that absolutely so much you
want to apologize to the city of Deer
Park and the people who have lived under
this cloud we did say one question at a
time we've got to move on Oh her choice
if she wants to answer it
David so we do have LPG LPG lawns on the
property but all the LPG lawns that are
in that proximity have been evacuated we
did that two days ago yeah I mean it's
around that Dyke time forum area so it's
it's one of those concerns where they're
keeping that peace pipe and everything
in that area cool
and I will answer your question if I
heard it correctly am I gonna apologize
you want it you want to apologize you
want to talk to the people that have
lived under this cloud now for going on
three days I I think I've said it the
best way that I can possibly say it of
course ITC is very sorry that this
unfortunate event this isn't an event we
wanted or planned many of my employees
work in the civil of their part
they live in Deer Park they're out there
fighting this fire the best they can
they they are residents I would guess
that probably thirty percent live in
Deer Park in the port their concern
their families are concerned so of
course I TC would apologize to any of
them
any more questions that's it thank you
so much